typically talk about it
about what science is doing is is that
what makes science special in some sense
is that
one scientist can look at a physical
system like this
um animal or this planet and another
scientist can make their own independent
measurements of that animal that
specific animal or that planet
and then we can go and compare notes in
other words we have this notion of
public physical objects objects that are
really there
whether or not we exist like dinosaur
bones right
the dinosaur bones have been there for
200 million years they they were there
if no one had ever been around they
would still be there
i can look at the dinosaur bones you can
look at the dinosaur bones they're
public physical objects we can make our
measurements
get the dna and so forth that's gone
in my point of view that whole point of
view is gone because space time itself
is doomed
spacetime isn't fundamental there are no
public physical objects so how do we
rethink
what we mean by objectivity in science
where objectivity is it has to do with
again
having independent scientists do their
own experiments and come to some
agreement
so the framework that i'm working on
right now
poses that as a really serious question
and so we're writing a paper on that
right now and we're going to be running
simulations but but
here's the kind of idea that i'm playing
with i think
that we have to take the possibility of
synesthesia
very seriously we actually know
synesthesia occurs
it could be easily in the cards that
your visual experiences
that you described with the words red
and round and
square and so forth and i described if i
could get inside your head
for all i know i would go whoa whoa
that's not what i would call
red and round that's what i would call
the smell of garlic and the taste of
butter um or or a headache those are
the just like michael watson
he he tastes mint but he feels a tall
cold smooth column of glass
i don't feel that if all michael watson
ever experienced were the feelings in
his hand
he would have a perfectly good taste
sensation he could cook
he could figure out what what foods are
so in other words we could you and i as
scientists
could absolutely agree
believe that we're talking the same
language and yet your
experiences could be synesthetically
utterly different from mine
and we would never know and i think that
that's
going to turn out to be a fundamental
and unbreachable limit
to what we can know and to
the degree of objectivity that we can
have in science
we the technical thing would be that we
can only agree
up to effectively a homomorphism
a homomorphism of your set of perceptual
representations and experiences
and mine the homomorphism could be as
radical as the difference between
the taste of mint and a tall cold smooth
column of glass it could be
that different and we would never know
the only reason we know of michael
watson's case is because he had both and
he could tell us about both
we could say oh well i understand the
one but gee i never thought about the
other
that's that's incredible um so
so we're going to have to understand
what is the most
confirmation and what's the greatest
level of agreement
that scientists can have given this
possibility of synesthetic complete
divergence between us
and i would love to i was talking with
my colleagues on this
in the paper that we're writing we may
actually do this
not just as a thought experiment paper
we may actually do this i would love to
create this really interesting virtual
reality game
two-player game or multiplayer but
for one player it's it it they're
immersed in what
seems like say grand theft auto
player is immersed in a completely
different game like super mario brothers
but i've arranged it so they both think
that they're playing the same game and
they
are actually playing and they win and
lose and but they have no idea that the
other person is in a completely
different virtual world
and they but they're also they're
they're using language they seem to
agree
right you take them out of their heads
and have them swap and
blow their minds when they find out what
the other person was doing i think we
can do that
and so we have to be if that's true if
that's possible
in category theory that would be the
idea that you might have
this one category for your
representation
the other scientists might have another
category but if there's some functor
if there's some functor that maps the
objects and relations
that you have in your interface to the
objects and relations that the other
scientist has in their interface if you
have the right functor
then the scientists will have the
appearance of agreement and they will
never know that they're
separated by this functor and
so i think that there's going to be
category theoretic analyses ahead um
on this that are going to be really
quite stunning but i think that's going
to be the future of the philosophy of
science
is this category theoretic fundamental
limitation on the
agreement that scientists can have there
are no public physical objects
so what does it mean for us to get
laboratory independent verification my
laboratory gets it
your laboratory gets it what are we
really doing in that case it's going to
be up to some functor
right it sounds to me i only have three
three more questions and they might be
long but
i have three questions it sounds to me
like you're saying that there are some
homomorphic
functions between us and that's
responsible for
why we feel like we share a similar
world however can we not use the same
argument that you use to show that the
probability that we see the truth is
zero that is that the immiscible
functions
grow much larger than the homomorphic
functions to the structure
can we not use that to say that the
probability that we share
any interfaces also zero including
homomorphic
right aspects um not not at least within
the theory of
conscious agents and the dynamics that
i'm talking about now because what we
can do is we can ask
are there certain strategies of
interaction
that conscious agents can have where
they would converge in the limit
to homomorphic things right so that's
different evolutionary game theory where
the rules have been spelled out i mean
i in that i don't get to play with them
because they're constraints so it's not
just uniform probability
that that's right so i see i see so in
the case of conscious agents
the question is can we find dynamics
in which the agents can converge up to
homomorphisms and i think we can